[Music]
three counties in California taking it
one step further defying the governor's
stay-at-home order allowing businesses
to reopen joining us now from the Golden
State is the author of the new book
don't burn this book thinking for
yourself in an age of unreason David
Rubin hey David
hey good morning everybody
good morning we're gonna talk about the
book coming up but first we wanted to
get your reaction about these three
counties in California Gavin Newsom has
said stay at home and these counties are
saying look we don't even have there's
one of those counties does even have a
case not one kovat case so they're
saying why do we have to follow these
rules
California's huge it's not a
one-size-fits-all thing what do you say
yeah well as you guys know I'm in
California right now it's super early
it's still dark so I was able to walk my
dog this morning without having a
neighbor snitch on me that's one thing
that apparently our mayor Eric Garcetti
wants but in terms of the whole state
and what Gavin Newsom is doing you know
if you take the beaches away from
Californians it was about 85 and sunny
this weekend the entire time not a cloud
in the sky it's like it's like why are
we paying these crazy taxes you know we
have but we have a state that the
infrastructure is failing our education
system is terrible and it's like without
the beaches without the ability to be
outside and you know I'll give Trump
credit where it's due it's like yeah of
course open up the beaches make sure
people our social distancing but the
idea that you can't walk out there with
the towel sit with your family stay far
away from somebody else wear a mask if
need be etc etc it's like just because
they have the power to do something
doesn't mean they automatically should
and they don't really explain why
they're doing it so you may have seen
the video of the the deputy mayor of Los
Angeles in a helicopter and he's showing
a completely empty beach and the way he
tweeted it implied that he was sort of
proud of it and it's like that's that's
really a recipe for a disaster in a
state like this and I know a lot of
Californians that are thinking of
looking at Texas and Florida and
Washington and some of these other
states well you know what Dave wall of
the
beaches are locked down in California
their clothes there yesterday we ran
some video earlier of this great big
Trump boat parade that went from Jupiter
Inlet down to mar-a-lago where I think
there were six or seven hundred boats
everybody was flying Trump flags
everybody was social distancing but it's
a tale of two different states
what does California know that Florida
doesn't know well I don't think
California knows anything that Florida
doesn't know Florida may know something
that California doesn't know I think
when you have big government
progressives in charge of the city here
in Los Angeles and then the state itself
it's like they like the opportunity to
use state power and all of us have been
trapped in our houses for two months we
haven't rioted we've done things right
we've we've gotten through this
unemployment we tried to help each other
I now know more of my neighbors from the
last two months than I have in the
previous two years we're going out of
our way to do good at the individual
level but I think some of these people
come in and then they think that it's
their job to just tell us all absolutely
how to live and it's not to say that we
should just open up just like that and
there's a one-size-fits-all policy to do
it obviously it's different in every
state New York has a particular
situation that say Montana doesn't have
now California may have a unique
situation but it's like if you don't let
us go to the beach if you don't let us
I can't just invite two friends over for
dinner at the moment I'm fairly certain
that I can't even if they've been
quarantine and I've been quarantined
it's like if you don't let us do these
things and at some point people will
break and you know what I think that
what I think that the progressives are a
misunderstanding here is that Americans
love Liberty Americans love being free
we will be responsible and we're willing
to take some risk but we can't live like
rats trapped in our houses forever
absolutely I just said I just saw that
in Illinois they say you could take your
boat out only with two people really if
you have a family of four and you've
been holed up with that family of four
you got to tell two of the little kids
to stay home because obviously they're a
threat meanwhile let's talk about your
book
don't burn this book thinking for
yourself in the age of unreason give me
an example of the unreason how we all
see it but in many cases were afraid to
point it out because of ridicule
yeah well that's exactly the the thesis
of the book that there are way too many
I would say almost the largest growing
political movement in the United States
right now is good decent people who are
just afraid to say what they think they
are afraid of the mob they are afraid of
outraged culture of canceled culture and
I'm not talking about people with truly
nefarious political beliefs I'm talking
about people who maybe just want lower
taxes and then they're afraid that
they're gonna be called racist I mean
really sort of crazy stuff that we've
seen this Twitter mob and the online mob
go after people's jobs it goes after
virtually every Fox host for saying
things and there's a reason that they do
this because they're just trying to
instill fear in people and I'm someone
that's been through many versions of
this myself
and as you guys know you know I'm a
former lefty that has moved right in me
in recent years and one of the things
that the left doesn't like is they don't
like like when one of their people walks
so I've been through the outrage machine
and I've survived it and really this
book is a tip on how to think for
yourself you know we live in a time
where everyone seems to think oh you
have to check off the ten boxes that the
lefties want or the ten boxes that the
righties want and that's the only world
that we can exist in and yet most of us
we have a diverse set of views and I try
to lay out what my political views are
and show people you know you don't you
if you have eight of these ten things
that's okay too
and you know we're too obsessed with
political parties instead of thinking
about really what what makes us better
as a nation the things that I think make
us better our limited government our
states rights things that we're suddenly
talking about states rights which not
you pretty great we haven't talked about
that in America in a long time and an
individual rights more than anything
else if you're a member of America if
you're a legal citizen in America you
should be treated exactly the same under
the law as anybody else okay Dave
congratulations on the book Dave Rubin
if you want to pick up his book it's
don't burn this book thinking for
yourself in an age of unreason
have a good one if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlists all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell